There's a tipping point.
It was corruption much direction
before you hit that tipping point.
And so what that means is the moral
behavior of each individual is far more
important that people generally think,
cause it doesn't take many
cheaters getting away with
it to make those who don't
cheat think that they're fools.
It's the probability of being caught.
That's the deterrent,
isn't the severity of the punishment.
Okay.
We know that that doesn't,
that isn't questionable.
We know that that's the case.
And I don't know why conservatives don't,
the reason they don't get
it is because they vote by,
you know,
they think by their temperament
and their temperament says punish.
It's not thinking it's just
a temperamental response.
Whereas the liberal responses,
well,
you know,
those poor criminals must've had something
happened to them that was terrible in
their past or they wouldn't be criminals,
which is,
you know,
just equally as nonsensical.
Yeah.